[Music]
on this Wednesday night sounding the
alarm about overwhelmed pediatric
hospitals we need to do everything
possible to help our children we're just
not doing it the repeated calls for
action and why the surge in patients
could extend beyond the new year
incoming white out the storm that could
affect millions of Canadians
fighting the rising tide of hate in the
U.S survivors of a mass shooting head to
Washington in search of action
fast
[Music]
reporting for Judy the South Korean
heartthrob trading in his microphone for
a military uniform
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
holiday season is a chance for family
get-togethers and social events
activities so many people crave after
the last couple of years but all that
close contact means a surge of colds flu
and covid-19 hospitals across the
country which routinely operated 100
capacity are now overwhelmed and much of
the concern is focused on facilities for
children Toronto's sick kids hospital is
one example it's been operating at 127
percent capacity for several days in a
row it's not just the volume of patients
it's how sick they are that's so
worrying more than half the children in
intensive care on a ventilator and
resources are so stretched non-urgent
surgeries are being canceled some
doctors say children are paying the
price for a crisis response that lacks
urgency nitu garcha has our top story
tonight
we wouldn't be in this crisis if this
wasn't a follow-up to kovid right in the
early stages of the pandemic the most
vulnerable were the elderly Dr Sanjeev
Gandhi says now the most vulnerable are
children kids are dying from this and
and we just don't see that in a normal
flu year or normal respiratory virus
season we're basically paying the price
for
pretending this pandemic was over before
it was really over the pediatric cardiac
surgeon says he's had to switch gears
recently to support patients with
respiratory illnesses in response to six
flu related deaths in children in BC
this season the provincial government
announced an influenza vaccine Blitz and
weekly reports on fatalities I don't
want to be hearing about weekly deaths
in kids like if it's to that stage like
we've lost the plot here I think it just
shows you the extent of the crisis in
Toronto for the first time sick kids
hospital is using a team of paramedics
from across the region to shuttle
patients to other hospitals to create
space inside the packed pediatric Ward
previously this didn't really have to
happen like they would you know spend
their whole time there and then get
discharged so the fact that they're
shuffling around like this shows that
there's great great stress on the system
during a briefing a bell respiratory
viruses on Wednesday Quebec's top doctor
urged people to avoid holiday parties if
they they have covid-19 we expect the
covet situation to get worse than it is
right now a similar message from
Canada's top Doctor Who says all
respiratory viruses including variants
of covid and RSV continue to burden the
Health Care system with hospitals across
Canada already at capacity it doesn't
take much to force them above capacity
the impact particularly on children's
hospitals has already been overwhelming
back in BC Dr Gandhi is calling for
stricter measures to help protect
children including easier access to
vaccines more testing in children so
doctors like him know what they're
treating and the elephant in the room is
the masks
we have to have an indoor mask mandate
we need to do everything possible to
help our children we're just not doing
it but when it comes to mandating that
measure Health officials in BC and
across the country remain reluctant
Garcia Global News West Vancouver BC
a nasty weather front is hitting parts
of this country it's connected to a huge
storm in the United States that's
stretching North from the Gulf Coast at
its peak the system is expected to be
more than 3 000 kilometers long right
now Manitoba and Saskatchewan are
beginning to Bear the brunt with heavy
snow and high winds forecast conditions
are deteriorating rapidly Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell is
tracking this Anthony what are we in for
Donna next up Southern Ontario
eventually Quebec and Atlantic Canada
it'll be mostly snow for these locations
it's been snowing all day in southern
Saskatchewan Manitoba Northwestern
Ontario you can see the swirl the center
of the low up over the Dakotas but the
front the cold front extends all the way
into the middle of the Gulf Coast and
it's on this southern end there's a lot
of energy a lot of moisture and heat
that's clashing with that colder air and
creating ideal conditions for severe
weather a multi-day tornado outbreak
continuing right now that moisture as it
lifts North it encounters some colder
air so it's more snow than anything but
there is the risk of freezing rain
tomorrow morning for parts of Southern
Ontario this low
not to be confused with this low that's
what's brought all sorts of inclement
weather snow and wind to Atlantic Canada
as well you'll see a one-two punch
because this system then one in the
midwest is headed your way this weekend
so for Friday there it is still snowing
in eastern Ontario into Quebec amounts
will be significant we are talking
anywhere from 10 to as much as 20 or 30
centimeters as far as Manitoba and
Saskatchewan this will be over multiple
days heading even into early Saturday
morning for Ontario and Quebec most of
it falls on Thursday and then the system
pushes east of course there are warnings
in place and we'll be tracking it from
the weather center Donna okay we hope
you will Anthony Farnell in Toronto
thanks the chair of Winnipeg's police
board is apologizing for saying a search
of a landfill for the remains of
murdered indigenous women is beyond
police capability and that the families
and Advocates should Lobby Ottawa to
make it happen happen in a statement
counselor Marcus Chambers says he
sincerely apologizes for any harmful
impact to a community still grieving a
35-year-old man is charged with
first-degree murder in the deaths of
Mercedes Myron Morgan Harris and Rebecca
quantois and a fourth woman the remains
of three of those women have yet to be
found Melissa region is following this
in Winnipeg Melissa what's the reaction
to what the police board chair said
well Donna that was met with
disappointment and a bit of outrage from
missing and murdered indigenous women
and girls Advocates who say that if
Winnipeg Police feel they're not up to
the task the city of Winnipeg or the
Manitoba government should be lobbying
the federal government for support not
to put that responsibility or on
indigenous people or families of
murdered women Advocates like the
national family and Survivor circle and
a growing number of chiefs across the
country have now called on Ottawa to
step in and find a feasibility study for
research fund the search itself which
could be in the double digit millions
and all of this should be overseen by
the United Nations special rapporteur on
the rights of indigenous people there's
a two-tier system in Canada you know
that's really rooted in structural and
systemic racism there's one for
non-indigenous people and there's one
for indigenous people in the quality and
the quantity of service we receive does
not meet the basic human rights
standards it's believed two women are
buried at a landfill under 40 feet of
densely compacted waste and keep in mind
it's December member the ground is
Frozen now in Winnipeg archaeological
experts told global news that it's on
the high end of a complex landfill
search but it is doable and families say
it's the right thing to do to give the
victims dignity and them closure Donna
all right Melissa Ridge and Winnipeg
thank you along the U.S Mexico border
thousands of people are trying to cross
into the United States as many as 10 000
people are believed to be making that
Crossing every day and 2.4 million have
already made the Trek this year more
migrants are expected to attempt it when
a trump-era border restriction known as
title 42 expires on December 21st most
of the people come from Honduras El
Salvador Guatemala and Mexico and in
Europe thousands of people are risking
their lives to cross the English Channel
in small boats hoping to start a new
life in the UK early this morning one of
those boats capsized a rescue mission
involved a fishing boat the Coast Guard
the Royal and French navies and police
dozens of people were rescued from The
Frigid Waters off the Southeast coast of
England but at least 4 died the English
Channel between France and England is
about 34 kilometers wide it can be rough
and it's a route migrants have used in
increasing numbers in recent years as
Crystal gomancing Reports there's
growing anger the UK government has been
turning a blind eye
yet another life loss despite
authorities knowing it would happen
again crossing the English Channel is
currently the only option for many
desperate people
the dangerous Journey to the UK often
includes paying thousands of dollars to
a Smuggler or a spot on a dinghy like
this one I'm sure the whole house will
share my sorrow at the capsizing of a
small boat in the channel in the early
hours of this morning and the tragic
loss of human life a fishing boat was
the first to respond to a Mayday call
Wednesday
What followed was a multinational
day-long search and Recovery operation
43 people men women and children were
pulled alive from the sinking boat it
was one of a handful attempting the
journey to date an estimated 45 thousand
have made that Crossing but it could
reach 50 000 by the end of the year
last year following the deaths of 27
people in the channel the government
launched a Crackdown it said people
would stop Crossing if they knew they'd
be turned away and struck a deal to send
people to Rwanda for processing and
resettlement that scheme is on hold
following a European Court of Human
Rights challenge it is not cruel or
unkind to want to break the Stranglehold
of the criminal gangs who trade in human
misery and who exploit our system and
our laws a different tone from Sue Ella
Braverman who at the end of October
likened The Landings on England's
Southern Shore to an invasion telling
the commons let's stop pretending that
they are all refugees in distress one of
the main tragedies is unfortunately it
will probably happen again unless the UK
government changes its policies around
migration specifically there are calls
for an office on the French side of the
channel so people can claim Asylum them
and for more resettlement programs
similar to the one created for
ukrainians Crystal gemancing Global News
London
Canada is revoking the exemptions it
made to sanctions allowing a Montreal
company to repair turbines for the
nordstream one natural gas pipeline
operated by the state-owned Russian
company gazprom in July Siemens energy
was granted an exemption to Canada's
sanctions so it could have up to six
turbines for the pipeline repaired at a
Siemens facility in Montreal
Ottawa says the decision to revoke that
temporary waiver was made because Russia
failed to return the nordstream pipeline
to full capacity once Canada agreed to
return a turbine in July at the time
Canada issued the waiver Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski called the
move absolutely unacceptable
a community in search of help coming up
survivors of another hateful U.S mass
shooting press Congress to act now
today marks 10 years since the world
heard the name Sandy Hook Elementary the
mass shooting at that school in Newtown
Connecticut was horrifying today flags
were lowered in the community people
honored the victims by visiting a new
permanent Memorial that opened last
month 20 first grade students were shot
and killed along with six adults it was
such a terrible senseless crime there
was hope it would finally trigger
Americans to recognize they need tighter
gun control laws but little has changed
survivors of a more recent mass shooting
at a Colorado nightclub were in
Washington today the lgbtq2 plus
Community has increasingly become
targets of shootings protests and
hateful rhetoric and as Jackson prosco
reports the fear is that even as the
Biden Administration takes steps to
enshrine rights like same-sex marriage
into law it might not be enough to
counter the rise in extremism
I ran for my life that night and hid
praying and helping the violence would
end less than a month after their safe
space came under attack survivors of the
Club Q shooting brought their stories to
Washington I fell over on the ground
knowing I had been shot
in my right arm the November massacre at
the Colorado lgbtq Club left five dead
and 18 wounded an alleged hate crime at
a time when lgbtq Americans are under
increasing threat we are being
slaughtered and dehumanized across this
country in communities you took oath to
protect survivors point to a sharp rise
in anti-gay and anti-transgender
rhetoric that's become mainstream this
is an effort to degrade the country to
make it into a joke from the most
watched cable news channel the end goal
is the normalization of pedophilia right
to the mouths of politicians they
support
sexualizing kids in kindergarten that is
harmful it's extremely harmful and it is
what spurred the attack at Club Q I do
blame the rise in hateful rhetoric
especially around trans individuals
especially around drag performers
they're not groomers they're just people
[Music]
increasingly the lgbtq2 community is
under threat drag performances have
faced protests and bomb threats
the worrying climate was recognized by
President Joe Biden Tuesday as he signed
Federal protections for same-sex
marriage racism
semitism homophobia
the antidote hate is love love may be
protected in law survivors of the Club Q
Massacre fear it won't be enough to turn
the rising tide of hate hate speech
turns into hate action and actions based
on hate almost took my life from me at
25 years old Jackson prosco Global News
Washington
funding focused research ahead the push
for home-grown scientific innovation
from the space race to the race to
create covid-19 vaccines to yesterday's
announcement about nuclear fusion there
is plenty of proof of just how effective
so-called moonshot projects can be now
as David Aiken reports there's a push
for the Canadian government to dream and
spend big
one
of the original moonshot research
programs was just that
putting a human being on the moon
and this week the latest payoff in
moonshot research well this one the
nuclear fusion I would call a sunshot
because of course what powers the sun is
nuclear fusion for decades it's been the
U.S government that led the world in
funding and focusing research moonshots
if we want those kind of breakthroughs
and I think we do
for all kinds of reasons government has
to be there to fund the moonshots the
private sector won't sometimes Canada
helps with International Moon shots for
example some of the research that helped
discover mRNA vaccines happened at
Hamilton's McMaster University
but Canada's science policy has tended
to be more risk-averse incremental good
evening colleagues but maybe no longer
kind of funding do we need several weeks
ago MPS on the house of common science
committee started putting together the
framework for Canada's first ever
moonshot research program oh that was
great I was very excited to hear that
there was an interest for this kind of
thing experts say the key to a
successful moonshot program the
anti-rotation is identifying the mission
find a focus or two for Canadian
research new technologies for fighting
climate change
or to deal with pandemics and infectious
diseases or uncomfortable resistance
which are all areas where
there is not enough research being done
these are societal needs that we have
identified as a society Canada's
Innovation minister is enthusiastic
about the potential my message to
everyone is I want to lead I want us to
be ambitious I want us to seize the
moment so what are the elements you know
funding is one then is the organization
of research and Science in Canada and
then third I would say how who and in
which field can we partner
internationally
now if it happens look for Ottawa to
take its first steps towards moonshot
research by the spring of next year
David Akin Global News
Ottawa
in the House of Commons today the Prime
Minister LED tributes to Winnipeg MP Jim
Carr who died Monday of blood cancer
Carr was respected by politicians of all
stripes and continued his work as an MP
until days before his death
in October
he told me that he was stopping
treatment
it was a private moment
in his hometown
Jim knew it was for the best
Trudeau said Carr embodied
characteristics common in people from
the Prairies clear-headedness pragmatism
and dedication Carr sought to work with
people on all sides of the house and
worked right until Lee Andy died days
after his private members Bill building
a green Prairie economy passed in the
House of Commons
from music to the military next why the
world's biggest K-pop group is going on
hiatus
[Music]
you may not know much about K-pop but if
you do you know all about BTS the Korean
pop music stars of Smash song records
stolen millions of Hearts well now the
group is going on Hiatus because his
oldest member has a duty to fulfill he
has to serve in South Korea's Military
Mike troulet looks at how die-hard fans
and even the Korean economy are taking
the news
inside one of these unmarked Vans
private gin the South Korean Army's
latest recruit Jin had hoped his arrival
would be private
but when you remember of the biggest
K-pop group in the world and top
streamer on Spotify privacy is next to
Impossible and BTS fans needed more than
this social media post showing off his
buzz cuter than expected he wrote uh we
are thought so quickly and see his cut
his hair yesterday and very very sad and
and probably realize this is real it's
mandatory for all Korean men to serve 18
months in the military jyn had been able
to put off his service until he turned
30 in deference to the immense power of
K-pop and while granting him an
exemption was fiercely debated BTS
ultimately decided all seven members
would serve one of the really
interesting things about this particular
situation is that since K-pop
contributes such a tremendous amount of
GDP to South Korea you have to wonder
what the economic effect of BTS
disappearing for a number of years is
going to be perhaps the closest
comparable is Elvis Presley who was
drafted in 1958 and served two years in
Germany others like Johnny Cash and Jimi
Hendrix enlisted before they were famous
it'll be interesting to see if BTS can
continue their success after the
reconstituted when everybody gets out of
the army will they grow with their
audience age With Their audience become
more mature or will they be Peter panish
and stay a boy band forever bts's rabid
fans are known as the Army they're
passionate and loud so perhaps real
military service will be a welcome break
for k-pop's biggest export microlight
Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
here in Canada is this festive cabin in
Spruce Grove Alberta beautiful we'd love
to see your festive Canada photos please
email them to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]